the anime world is full of insanely
creative and complex Power Systems but
none is as notoriously complex and
sometimes hard to follow as judu kaisen
to the point where characters in the
story are frequently confused by it
themselves and even the author Giga
kutami has admitted that he himself
could probably not explain it fully and
so to help him and anyone else having a
hard time here out we're going to do
exactly that and break down the entire
power system of Jud suisen and at the
base of it all it of course all really
boils down to Cursed energy to put it
simply cursed energy is born from humans
negative emotions fear sadness anger
Envy pretty much every person feels
these emotions at sometime and over time
they do leak out and accumulate
eventually manifesting themselves as
evil cursed spirits and you thought your
bad vibes were a problem now to make
sense of the complexity that is cursed
energy in the story let's try to
visualize this a little bit this power
system is a whole lot like a tree in a
way yeah we actually came up with a
whole metaphor for this so cursed energy
is basically the foundation of every
Power in this fictional world so it's a
whole lot like the roots here everything
else grows from the basis of cursed
energy however some people with a high
enough threshold of cursed energy can
actually learn to see these curses and
even control the cursed energy within
themselves and so enter the art of
jujitsu now these called jiujitsu
Sorcerers use cursed energy for their
own purposes and are able to manipulate
it in order to fight and exercise these
bad cursed spirits and so kind of
continuing our tree visualization here
once you have enough cursed energy
within you to be able to actually see
and perceive energy and Spirits it's
kind of like a sapling has broken
through the soil while everybody else is
still buried under ground and unaware of
the real world of cursed energy around
them those who have broken through the
surface can now finally see the world of
jiujitsu in all its glory and so since
we've made it here starting with the
very Basics the ground floor of judu
sorcery is just being able to detect
cursed energy yet alone control it with
the ability to actually detect cursed
energy Sorcerers can see cursed spirits
but they can also detect the energy of
other sorcerers and so they can kind of
estimate the potential strength of an
opponent by measuring the amount of
energy that they Amit sometimes they can
even track a large amount of cursed
energy to its source by following its
tracks or even identify a sorcerer
specifically based on their cursed
energy signature but of course just
being able to see a terrifyingly
powerful Spirit Beast is a long way from
actually being able to kill the thing so
let's move on from the grounds here now
as you know eventually we're going to
get into some truly crazy and honestly
very unique powers and techniques here
but first let's again stay with the
fundamentals and once you can actually
detect cursed energy the next step is to
actually gain control over your own you
see since cursed energy comes from
negative emotions gaining control over
one's emotion is very crucial here and
so that's why in order to train Yuji for
instance Gojo uses the method of asking
him to watch very emotional movies while
channeling his energy into the spirit
cursed doll and so as a result this
makes judu the only power system where
watching a romantic comedy is actually
more effective than doing push-ups and
so at this point once you gain control
over your emotions and therefore your
cursed energy you can now start actually
applying it in combat to some level by
controlling your cursed energy output
the energy can be channeled into a
user's fist for instance for physical
attacks it can also be used to code your
skin for added defense against enemy
attacks and some users can even expel
raw cursed energy for a ranged attack or
Channel their energy into weapons to
strengthen them as well and in fact if
enough cursed energy is channeled into
an object over time it can actually turn
into a cursed tool now as you keep on
training your cursed energy and you're
able to manipulate it it's kind of like
you're developing the trunk of your judu
tree the greater your command of cursed
energy itself the thicker your trunk and
the stronger your bark so a beginner
like Yuji at the beginning of the story
is just a sapling while Gojo is like
this massive California redwood tree
that you could drive a whole car through
underneath and so when fighting using
your cursed energy if the user's control
is precise enough a special phenomenon
can actually happen here's how if a
sorcerer physical attack like a punch
hitting syncs up with the application of
your cursed energy within
0000001 seconds the result is a black
flash which amplifies the power of that
hit now there's actually no judu
sorcerer that can actually use this
technique at will since it does require
such insane amounts of precision but a
skillful enough curse user can make it
happen more frequently than others
nanami here actually once held the
record for four black flashes in a row
until Yuji here surpassed it while
fighting MTO and really if anything I
feel like it just goes to show you that
there's no point in actually working
hard at your day job if there's a lesson
to take away here just take one of
life's shortcuts and eat some disgusting
old fingers now one of the hardest
abilities in judu kaisen to really wrap
your mind around is actually r verse
cursed energy that's because you
actually do need to know uh some math
for that one and as we all know if
you've at least passed fifth grade level
maths multiplying two negative numbers
together actually creates a positive
therefore by multiplying two streams of
negative cursed energy together one can
actually activate a reverse curse
technique which creates positive energy
and so unlike normal cursed energy which
can only be used to cause harm and
destroy the reverse cursed energy can
actually be used to heal damage and
apparently the logic here is well it's
positive which equals good so I guess it
must heal you and the author needed a
way for characters to actually somehow
survive the crippling wounds that they
receive from other characters so this
was a very solid solution I think so you
know something like a massive head
trauma from being stabbed in your brain
is no problem anymore thanks to reverse
curse technique and so now that we've
got our Basics covered pretty well it's
actually time for the bread and butter
of the judu kaisen PO system which are
cursed techniques and this is where we
start to get really crazy unique powers
that make judu kaisen battles some of
the most intriguing and at times
admittedly confusing fights in all of
Shonen anime I think and so unlike other
battle manga where it might be a bit
annoying here we actually encourage all
of the characters on the sideline to
give us a play-by-play breakdown of the
fights here because without them
explaining everything that's going on
here we'd probably have no idea what's
going on most of the the time in short
curse techniques are special abilities
unique to a user fueled by that user's
cursed energy in fact most Sorcerers and
also curses have an innate technique
which is assigned to them at creation or
birth that technique then begins to
manifest in childhood and can grow and
develop along with its user as they grow
stronger and older now in the vast
majority of cases Sorcerers only have
access to one of these techniques
throughout their life and they cannot be
replicated or taught in extremely rare
cases though a user can use multiple
curses techniques but this is almost
unheard of in the world of Jutsu kaisen
but it does exist and so most
importantly of all how do these
techniques now fit into our tree example
here well since curs techniques manifest
themselves in all sorts of different
forms for different types of users they
are kind of like the branches of our
tree now you're getting it unlike
General cursed energy use which looks
the same for most users this is where
every judu sorcerer splits off in their
own unique Direction and the same of
course also goes for curses one major
exception to two techniques being unable
to be taught are inherited techniques
which are passed down genetically this
is especially common in the big three
families of judu sorcery that you've
definitely heard about which are the
zanan clan the Gojo Clan and the camo
Clan and so techniques like satarug
Gojo's Limitless the Zan Clan's 10
shadows and the C's blood manipulation
are so powerful precisely because their
strength has been honed and perfected
across many many generations going back
thousands of years the 10 Shadows
technique used by Figo in particular is
an example of a shikigami summoning
technique shikigami are these monstrous
creatures that resemble cursed spirits
that a user can summon at will and then
use as a familiar kind of controlling
them now most chiky gum users not from
the say Clan are only able to conjure
one shikigami to act as a partner at a
time but megumi's 10 Shadows technique
that he inherited allows him to utilize
several different ones tend to be
precise as the name says now now many
very powerful Sorcerers can be born to
non sorcerer families but also have
access to curse techniques that are not
inheritance some examples here include
for example ao's Boogie woogi or Kenton
nanami's ratio technique and even suguru
gto's cursed Spirit manipulation was a
non-inherited technique which just shows
that even Sorcerers who aren't born to
The Big Three Families can still achieve
the status of being a special grade so
kind of weird that he ended up being the
one super into non curse user racism
type of person I mean kind of like I
guess Voldemort being halfblood himself
and you know not liking anyways that's a
whole different story now in addition to
these cursed techniques there are also
different categories of non- innate
techniques as well the most common ones
of these that we see in the series are
the so-called barrier techniques
abilities like curtain that allow
sorceress to seal off an area while they
hunt down cursed Spirits in order to
keep civilians from witnessing any
Supernatural combat and to prevent them
from being caught up in the cross fire
as well now going back to our fantastic
judu tree here these sparia techniques
are kind of like the leaves that
surround the remains of the branches
these leaves expand outward making the
whole tree appearance larger and Fuller
just like a barrier expands a user's
cursed energy beyond their own body and
yes of course the most hyped version of
that barrier technique is actually a
domain expansion this is basically where
a cursed energy user will erect a
barrier that is powered by their own
curse technique and this is usually the
most powerful technique that any judu
sorcerer can actually use because within
that domain their techniques are
Amplified and even guaranteed to hit
their target every single time for
example Gojo's standard Limitless
technique that he inherited from the
Gojo family allows him to use the power
of infinity so that his opponents can
never fully reach him and he can also
manipulate space itself to repel or
attract opponents however his domain
expansion unlimited void is on a a whole
different level here that's because this
power floods the minds of anyone trapped
within this expanded domain with
infinite amounts of information
overwhelming their brain to the point of
being completely unable to move or do
anything basically forcing them to
experience what feels like an eternity
before they finally die unable to do
anything about it now some other domain
expansions simply relentlessly attack
the opponent for instance joo's coffin
of the Iron Mountain simply tries to
bust the opponent inside a giant volcano
where sukuna malev and Shrine subjects
its victims to a flurry of slashing
attacks now these a little bit more
typical domains are all about raw
offensive power after all there's not
much that your opponent's weird super
special unique techniques can do against
you if they're already dead nonetheless
some of them are a lot more reality
warping and complex and trying to
understand their mechanics can even be
brain breaking to the viewer himself for
instance higuma here is a courage user
who is also a lawyer who uses his deadly
sentencing which basically traps his
opponents in a court of law where all
violence is prohibited and a shikigami
called judgment determines his
opponent's guilt or innocence in other
words Jutsu kaizen's Powers go Way
Beyond punching to say the very least
now the drawback of these extremely
powerful techniques is that they use up
an incredible amount of cursed energy in
fact Gojo here is one of the only
characters in the entire series who can
actually use his domain expansion
multiple times per day and the
scientific explanation for that is that
this is Satur Gojo and he's so powerful
that he can destroy the part of his
brain that is responsible for producing
cursed energy and then just healing it
to replenish that yeah it's it's kind of
that level of thing now with these
domain expansions there are of course a
few ways that a user can actually
counter this power as well for example
by casting a so-called simple domain
within an opponent's domain expansion a
cursed user can avoid the guaranteed hi
rule with their own domain without the
need to expand their own cursed energy
necessary for a full domain expansion
themselves and as you guess the other
couns of measure is simply to go
head-to-head with your own domain
expansion in what is called a domain
Clash basically as long as the domains
are evenly matched against each other
the guaranteed hit will be canceled out
however as soon as one of the domains
wins over the other basically meaning
one person runs out of cursed energy
that attack will take effect immediately
and then another different but also very
important element of the judu kaisen
power system comes in the form of cursed
restrictions now in case you're familiar
with hun Hunter these kind of function
in the same way as nen contracts by
placing various conditions upon your own
powers Sorcerers can basically unlock
greater Feats of Strength when those
conditions are met and so going back to
our beautiful in Lush judu tree here
restrictions are basically the kind of
soil conditions that your tree is
growing in and so if you add some
fertilizer to the ground your tree is
going to grow much bigger and stronger
but in this case instead of putting on
your gardening glove you're more signing
a binding legal contract with a plant I
guess and personally one of the funniest
and most creative applications of this
in the entire story is when users curse
techniques actually get stronger if the
opponent is able to understand how that
power Works which means that judu kaisen
can use the age-old anime Trope of
people fighting overe explaining how
their powers work while they're going
head-to-head only that in judu it has an
actual in Universe reason for happening
and in most shows as you know this is
purely for the audience to be able to
follow along with the fight because
obviously by explaining your secret
technique to an opponent you're just
going to give them a very bad Advantage
by letting them understand your entire
power system however in judu kaisen the
author makes it so that these
explanations actually increase the
techniques power so there's actually a
reason for explaining them to us which
is great and so not only does it help us
make sense of things but it also adds
another layer of tactical strategy to
judu ka's brain banding battles by
withholding parts of their power or
misleading their opponent they can get
partial increases of power while still
maintaining the element of surprise
however while this is maybe the most
common version we see this isn't the
only application of a binding wow being
used in the story in fact one of maybe
the best examples is nanami's overtime
Wow Let Me Explain normally nanami's
power level is limited to only around
80% of his full power while he's on the
clock working for Jude soai basically
getting a paycheck for that however
whenever that time limit is exceeded and
his uh overtime begins he's able to
exceed his upper limit and output
120% of his maximum power instead then
there are also other vows who are
exchanged with other people instead of
the user themselves and the penalty for
breaking one of those vows is supposedly
much harsher than breaking a
self-imposed one and the most notable
example of one of these vows was
probably the deal made between Yuji and
sukuna where in sukuna healed yuji's
heart in exchange for giving him control
of yuji's body for one minute at a time
to be determined but the most extreme
example of a cursed vow is the so-called
Heavenly restriction now this is a
phenomenon where in a cursed user's
energy is reduced in exchange for
greater physical power or the opposite
can be true as well where in someone's
physical body can be a lot weaker in
exchange for greater cursed energy now I
mean of course there's probably also
people in the world of jutu kaisen who
are physically weak and have very little
cursed energy and I guess well sucks to
be them however one really good example
of a trade-off is kokichi muta AKA
mamaru his body was extremely weak and
feeble but his cursed energy could reach
an insane distance to be able to
remotely control mamaru however in the
case of migi's Father toji fushiguro the
opposite is true unlike most humans who
are born with at least a small amount of
cursed energy which is kind of how
cursed Spirits are produced in the first
place toi was instead born with
absolutely zero nothing at all however
in exchange for that as part of that
bargain he gained unparalleled speed and
strength in fact his five senses were
heightened to such a degree that he
could even see cursed energy and cursed
Spirits even though he possesses no
cursed energy himself making him
completely untrackable by other Judes
who users as well like he could even
sense slight changes in the air and
atmosphere around him however even
though toi was a complete monster he
could still not handle the unreal
strength of Satur goo in his backstory
toi was the toughest challenge that Gojo
faced as a young Sorcerer And it just
really makes you wonder what Gojo's
upper limitations truly are in the story
cuz he really only goes all out very
rarely I mean during the infamous
Shibuya incident he was even handicapped
by not wanting to hurt or kill any
civilians and so it really makes you
wonder how much he might have been able
to dominate the entire Universe there if
he had used his maximum power there and
conveniently we answered that exact
question right here in this video thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one